speaking of wanker shelby chris i know
another youtube creator you're very fond
of
nicaragua avocado right it's avocado
is he the guy that eats everything yeah
and cries yeah
what's the story behind him i mean i i'm
i'm not as good as you are like you're
like switched on i don't really know
in the youtube alone
i watched a four-hour video about him
that explained all his history and i
can't tell you anything about it oh the
right opinion video yeah it was
basically a guy just uh was getting
views doing mukbangs got fat and then
kind of just uh but he used to be like a
health conscious like vegan yeah he used
to be super thin
super healthy used to promote like
healthy eating an interesting character
yeah and then he did one mukbang saw how
big it got and then just oh that's sad
yeah that's really sad yeah yeah and
it's it's i think it's gone to the point
now where he is definitely playing a
character yeah he's playing it up he's
completely like but he's also very he's
also eating the food but he's also
killing himself it's uh it's method
acting
to the nth degree
i feel about eating fried chicken yeah i
i remember when daniel day lewis was uh
eating all the fried chicken
[Music]
that's sad though isn't it yeah which
mukbangs in general are like the saddest
thing on earth maybe i'll do it what are
you gonna do we basically did that
what you did already right the
ramen as well something sad is about
avocado i feel like a one-off
is
don't get cholesterol like him sort it
out i think
i might i don't want to you know assume
but i think you might have higher
cholesterol than me oh really what but
so he was health conscious when he got
rid of it he just was like no because
they didn't get views he didn't get
views yeah so money was more important
money and drama
got yeah he basically chased the money
and drama like training sorry yeah so
yeah him eating unhealthy and drama got
him more views which in turn got more
money so it was like a endless spiral
yeah it's a spiral i mean this is this
is the future of youtube though isn't it
no just punishing yourself for views i
mean i've done that plenty of times i
think like a mukbang every now and then
is like all right whatever you're not
sure putting your health at risk but
when you're like here's my my my daily
mukbang of yeah 1500 chicken nuggets
it's just like maybe this is a slice if
you're doing like a matt stoney where
it's like you know eat a gargantuan
amount of food once a month but also
work out vigorously
that's fine so that's what he does right
now steady well i think he i think a lot
of the professional leaders they they
eat that large amount of food and then
the days off they pretty much just don't
eat much yeah very very like precise
diet there's a there's a science there's
an ethic yeah yeah like it's like if you
eat seven thousand calories you've got
to figure out how you can get that out
of your diet yeah or you can have the
lack of calories yeah i think he
messaged me once because he did the
monster ramen challenge in akihabara
like three minutes in a way that i can
only dream of yeah um but i didn't
realize that he's actually quite good
about it he's like one of the like best
in the world an avocado man just [ __ ]
i don't even think he can eat as much as
max stoney like he is like insane yeah
that's not just like inhuman but like
he's also like pro like trained trained
professionally i guess to the point of
where he knows what he's doing is he
trained professionally well i mean i
guess i mean he competes he's like the
[ __ ] the king at it like no one beats
yeah i think it's like a few other
people who are pre as good as him like i
mean he's got a lot of the records i
think most of the stuff he knows what
he's doing yeah i think the reason why
he uh doesn't upload as frequently is
not just for health reasons but i think
it's also because he's like doing like
professional eating competitions like
wow right i mean i'm guessing it's still
not healthy what he's doing no you sent
me a video of him just hitting like a
hundred slices of cheese oh that was so
gross that looks this i wanted to throw
up just watching that video once he's
had his first endoscopy he'll think very
carefully
food fighting strategy i'm sure that man
has like the best healthcare that money
can buy
the camera
because what happened to that guy who
did a mandarin food
oh um adam um something adam's gonna say
adam levine and i was like
that's maroon
[Laughter]
chicken challenge
100 pizzas
after a bucket of chicken i mean it's
just depressing isn't it i feel like
there's only so much you can do before
you just like i don't i don't like this
anymore i'm just hurting myself
i'm just in pain did you not feel like
that after you did your cup noodle
challenge were you going for awful
that's why that's why i only do it like
once every [ __ ] month after like one
cup needle i feel like
yeah but collectively you probably ate
about five or six cups yeah six or six
old cards brave map
it's a lot of sodium yeah too much
sodium iso too much
[Laughter]
well sodium it's one of those things
like you're not doing it often so
whatever really i mean cholesterol's
still high but you know are you going to
do more i tried xyz videos i tried
everything there's just not that much to
do that's interesting you're kind of
covered maybe christian was pretty
rubbish it was just like they all looked
the same but then it was also because i
just moved in and like everything was a
mess and we couldn't get any of the
camera set up or like filming connor's
apartment and like he had
no curtains yeah we had the curtains
right there to block out the sun we used
like
like 20 boxes and a blow-up doll or
something
his collection of dodgy
video tapes still he loves mother's nose
breasts
the masterpiece of our time he couldn't
stop giggling when he saw it he was like
what why is mother those breasts did
yesterday
you should have what is mother noise
what's his favorite shirt wonderful he's
these tapes to block out like the sun
it was yeah it did not work well and the
crisps were just they all were just so
[ __ ] there's nothing interesting about
it in the uk would have been
yeah what did uh somebody messaged me in
the week and said chris
your friends with the trash tastes loud
oh yeah and
of course i am i don't know if you next
time we see him tell him to stop going
so hard on america what have you done i
think it was you as well it's like
particularly in connor what have you
said about america that's made everyone
else
we've still said a lot of stuff we've
said a lot more than they've said about
the uk quite frankly
what's your opinion of america chris
that's right
i mean i don't it's silly to make
sweeping generalizations about the
entire country
it's not actually like generalizing the
entire population this is for jokes i
think in the uk
we're like a little bit snobby towards
americans of course we are going to
[ __ ]
car every garage chicken everything
towards everyone let's be honest we
invented the rocket engine
we are a little bit envious because we
had an empire and then it was gone and
then america had had a bigger and better
economy
you know i think i do you know i think
like british people hate about americans
is that they look happy
that's true you know i i
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the [ __ ] why are they so
happy they're not allowed to work that
makes sense what we should learn from
americans is it's good to like have
dreams and be optimistic
we don't have that in the uk i remember
like you know i used to work in office
and i'm like i want to start a business
they were like
[ __ ] off and get me my tea little prick
okay i like just having a dream in the
uk you just can't do that you're not
allowed
to shut up and make the tea
sit hey icarus give me my [ __ ] tea
like it's horrible the uk is horrible
could that possibly be a generalization
as well
imagining chris being scolded is the
funniest [ __ ] thing
just british people miserable we are
miserable i remember when elon musk came
to the castle where i worked right my
boss was really
up tight [ __ ] of a woman and she was
like really [ __ ]
really like she's very very posh like
when you work at a prestigious place you
get like really posh people though
this person i work with i just i just
just hated him because he was like
american
and he came with like lots of um
silicon valley investors and
all right right
new picture idea to them
that must be like the cringiest thing
you could possibly do oh yeah and then
they all just ha
i just want to talk to him and they like
let me deal with him and i'd like give
him the birthday cake because she didn't
want to she's like 50.
why didn't i
maybe show
if you go to a nice restaurant in japan
you just you don't feel judged it's nice
you go to a nice restaurant in the uk
like a michelin star sure yeah you will
feel like nothing you'll feel like
you're sure you feel out of place there
the class structure in the uk is pretty
powerful still and uh you know if you go
in a nice restaurant you often double oh
what are you doing here especially when
you turn up dressed like me
they're like oh gosh what are you doing
here
yeah the toilets are not here so like
it's just i don't really care where
you're from in japan but i feel like it
does matter a bit in the uk they're like
where did you grow up
it's just it's just fascinating coming
from a country that doesn't have that
they're like what this is like how does
like where does it start how do you
distinguish between who is in the same
classes
1 000 years of history and money
because there's like so much old money
there right so it gets inherited down
and they get uh brought up it just
sounds like my own [ __ ] circle in her
own [ __ ] environment it sounds like
racism within the same race i mean it's
called classism right yeah there's a
little name for it
yes i went to this uh fancy restaurant
in the uk and uh someone laughed at us
for wearing you know wearing like uniqlo
and h m clothes disgusting disgusting
huh which what person was this like a
waiter or no just just someone sitting
at a table we got we got looks for you
know having having like
smart business casual clothes yeah
obviously none of it was like name
brands if i turn up in my primark jacket
i was always on the mindset the real
rich people like actual rich didn't feel
the need to dress smart they just turned
up in like [ __ ] pajamas no but that's
like american british right where people
have new money in the uk yeah there's
old money right yeah
passed down
yeah it's like name value to the money i
feel really at my depth in london when i
when i go back
to this place like that's why i just buy
anything on one of the menu at
mcdonald's that's the real wealth that's
the flex power that's the real flex
right you guys want some nuggets i
suppose i could buy another 20. 20
pieces
it's like london five-star hotels are a
joke
like it's like it looks like my
grandma's bedroom
like it's it's old and quaint it's been
around for hundreds of years and it's
like yeah that's why my grandma still
has the [ __ ] bed it's [ __ ]
it's like this [ __ ] awful like you
know you see these rooms they have like
a a
12 inch screen from like the 1980s they
have these bed sheets that look like
they're just decrepid yeah this oak
cabinet that looks like it's been around
longer than like the entirety of london
it's like it's [ __ ] and you pay like 400
pounds a night yeah you get nothing i
mean i feel japan kind of has that as
well with some of their york arms as
well right i thought that until i stayed
in some of the london hotels and then
i'd forgotten how
how overpriced the service issue uh the
service industry is in the uk because
for for what you get in like the price
you pay for like you can be you can stay
in some like
five star hotels or whatever and you're
paying like four or five times the price
you would in japan and it would be like
half the size of the room with no
service it doesn't even come with
toothbrushes like like it doesn't even
come with toothbrushes which i think is
like the best
i remember that yeah because in japan
any even the worst hotel in the world
we got a cheese we got two strawberries
molds
exactly right i think the uk doesn't do
it for like environmental waste yeah
yeah
which also just suddenly lines up very
nicely for these hotels because they
don't have to buy toothbrushes yeah
yeah where where are the five stars
coming from in that case just just from
the name i don't understand how they get
five stars sometimes because i i think
it must be location half the time right
a lot of these five star hotels are in
amazing locations yeah but the hotels
are dreadful really bad don't go in a
five-star hotel london just go to like a
[ __ ] premier inn or some [ __ ]
yeah airbnb maybe airbnb is like way
better yeah you get way better london's
in airbnb yeah
in england in general like pretty much
every hotel i've stayed in in england
is like not the greatest i tell you the
time i got locked inside an airbnb in
england
i used to use airbnb a lot and then i
stayed in bath once for a holiday really
nice town called bath and uh it was in
like an attic
it's like quasimodo up there
but like i i yeah the door wasn't open
the door went open from the inside so as
i woke up that morning i was like i'm
gonna go for a jog around bath and uh
you went to the door just it just
wouldn't open i was like what the [ __ ]
and like there was no way i could open i
rang up the gut i was like hey man i
can't get out the apartment this is kind
of weird this hasn't ever happened in
the history of ever and it's oh it
happens sometimes um
you short run open i was like no i was
like can you come and say well i'm in
bristol at the moment which is about an
hour away i was like
there's a fire i'm [ __ ] and like and i
had to wait like an hour for someone to
come and like open the door and let me
out of the apartment so i was locked
inside and that put me off the airbnb in
the uk yeah the one did you uh leave a
bad review i think i did i was like got
locked in the room
who starts not as bad as it
that's the only thing that i sometimes
don't like about airbnb is that there is
some weird unpredictable
natures i did it in asakusa once and uh
the owner was like just just say you're
our friends
to say or you know just say you're
friends with takeshi i was like yeah all
right it's weird isn't it if someone
like you in the corner yeah takeshi's
tomodachi this yeah so you know if if
you're lugging around like expensive
equipment i wouldn't i wouldn't go an
airbnb right yeah just don't trust it
like if i have my laptop camera stuff
like that yeah you have no insurance you
have no safety you know and
if it's if someone else also has the
keys it's a bit worrying obviously the
hotel has
uh you know people say keys as well yeah
you can at least there's some level of
safety there and there's cameras
everywhere yeah it's also cameras
so it's you know it's it depends if i
was just traveling with me somewhere on
my own didn't bring my laptop around and
give a [ __ ]
and i tried to
last week when we were trying to make a
video we went to this really expensive
hotel room twelve 12 000 hotel room and
i wanted to contrast that with something
bad like a bad hotel room or a cheap
airbnb i'm trying to book three separate
airbnbs in tokyo and they're all like oh
it's open these few days i booked it and
three times in a row i got rejected uh
they were like no we're full of day i
got really angry at this point about
that i don't know if it's because i you
know i'm not japanese
uh a lot of people said afterwards that
they always book under a japanese name
i was quite disappointed about that i
was like oh maybe it's because of the
new omni variant and so they're being a
bit wary because i'm foreign